pa je mange la multiplicité des
candidatures est le fruit de la crise
dans laquelle nous sommes galles puis à
pas il n'y a pas une forme de ridicule
quand même il ya simplement une question
doit être posée
maintenant elle est simple c'est comment
faire pour que le parti socialiste
puisse repartir et chacun doit
maintenant défendre un plan de travail
et les idées moi c'est que ça qui
m'intéresse je les dis c'est pour ça que
je me précipite pas je construis je
discute je fais les propositions je
regarde
j'évalue et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
travailler et j'essaye de surtout de
créer un mouvement collectif des cadres
évaluerez vous déclare être candidat on
a jusqu'au 27
puisque c'est la date limite je dis pas
que je ferai le 27 si je prouve pas je
sais pas je discute en ce moment ça
l'est en ce moment vous avez bien
compris tout le monde discute tout le
monde se parle tout le monde essaye de
comprendre
voilà la raison doit finir par
l'emporter moi je les dis je le
maintiens qu'il ya la place pour tout le
monde c'est pas important la question de
savoir si on est numéro 1 au numéro deux
et la place pour tout le monde je pense
qu'il faut simplement une personnalité
qui puisse et c'est pour moi la chose la
plus importante à partir de j + ans
c'est à dire quand le congrès sera finie
mettre en mouvement le parti socialiste
le mettre en mouvement avec des formes
nouvelles
leur construire reconstruire sa colonne
vertébrale et avoir l'expérience
nécessaire pour faire bloc là vous
pourriez être cet homme et vous pourriez
vous allez remarquer que j'ai fait une
proposition et j'y tiens je serai pas
l'homme ce sera un couple oui c'est ça
non mais vous serez en cette veille de
votre interrogation pour l'instant
demeure simplement quand est-ce que vous
avez annoncé votre candidat mais voulait
one on est bien content et la tuerie et
goudé ne fait pas dans la queue vous
expliquer ce soir là je j'ai dit je
maintiens je construis si j'y arrive pas
si au final je vois une explosion de
candidature là un débat qui explose dans
tous les sens et c'est ça sera aussi un
constat de la situation du parti je
serai amené en tira cerdan le concluant
pour l'instant j'essaye de rassembler
tous ceux qui veulent que le parti
socialiste en sorte qu'ils veulent le
faire et avec sérieux avec détermination
et qui discutent sur le fond voilà
est-ce que